J yeah you are a magician well what a
magician good morning Hank it's Tuesday
the 8th episode adaptation of my first
novel Looking for Alaska comes out in
eight days on Hulu which means I'm
starting to think it's gonna happen in
the 14 years since the book was
published I have made many public
announcements that it was gonna be a
movie or a TV show or something only to
have that fall through which is often
the way of Hollywood but yeah this is
gonna happen I think I should say it's
also coming out in the UK on BBC three
and in Canada and Europe and Australia
and New Zealand and lots of other places
more info in the doobly-doo so listen
when this book was first published in
2005 around a third of my life ago I
never dared to imagine that it would be
in print 14 years later let alone that
it would still be finding lots of new
readers who now see the book of course
with its payphones and pre vaping
nicotine distribution systems as a kind
of historical fiction but I'm so
grateful that the story is still around
and so grateful to Stephanie Savage and
Josh Schwartz who have been working on
this adaptation for more than 10 years
the early reviews have been good and the
cast is so lovely as you're about to see
their chemistry is super real all right
guys don't be too weird in the
background
oh just go great I'm here with Christine
frozen aka last p.m. Jamie who plays the
coaming Sophie lastly Eva who plays a
lot of wickets kaya
Wow that's a very good accent for
somebody who doesn't normally have an
accent
thank you my Russian parents I can roll
my arse it's like a dream this entire
thing you know as any of your magic made
it into the show we'll leave that for
the viewers surprise I love it I love it
have you read the book yes I called my
mother at 3 in the morning from her
hotel room and cried and I read it in
one sitting
oh that's quite sweet it was really
wonderful do you know how John feels
about Keanu Reeves oh yes
John Green loves Keanu Reeves like my
level of obsession with J Cole I didn't
know that you were that into J Cole
oh I'm obsessed are you friends with him
I feel like you could be friends with
him no no no no you wrote an ex life oh
I just noticed your nail polish which
makes me want to cry oh jeez oh god it's
just intense for me man because it's
like a person I imagined is sitting next
to me it's weird I'm a crier I'm a crier
too
I love to cry what's your favorite act
at the circus I like the trapeze artist
everyone has said that so really yes we
pick a really good cast here what do you
think the meaning of life is oh that was
one I wanted to answer I'm gonna steal
my mom's words to be happy what's your
favorite act at the circus ooh the tiger
acts you're the first person not to say
the trapeze oh really
yeah that is a really good one I just
did not have pronounced this because you
are not your English is not your first
language no although you would think
that you don't have an accent really but
you are originally from Norway Finland
yes my Sweden
I will not yea get into that every time
somebody asks me where you're from
I'm always like oh God oh I know that
there's another Norwegian country and I
caramel what it's called they're all
even called Norwegian countries are they
they're called
have you cried on the set
yes first stiff on set obviously and
then when I walked into her room are
there any ways in which you are like
Alaska in real life I think our internal
lives are quite similar but externally
were very very different we have to
leave but we just started all right okay
couple more questions real quick real
quick what is what is the meaning of
life to be with the people that you love
to be happy annoys for yourself
wow that was incredibly judging quickly
yeah what would you have your last words
be I really hope you like the show again
it comes out on October 18th or October
19th if you live in some places I check
your local listings Hank I'll see you on
Friday